BRIAN:  AS THE BATTLE THAT WE’RE
FIGHTING HERE AGAINST THE VIRUS
RAGES IN THE U.S. AND AROUND THE
WORLD, OUR ADVERSARIES,
CHINA, RUSSIA AND IRAN ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC TO WEAKEN WESTERN
DEMOCRACIES, AND DISINFORMATION
AGAINST US, LET’S BRING IN THE
FOUR STAR GENERAL, SENIOR
STACK MILITARY COMMANDER,
GENERAL JACK KEANE.
GENERAL, WHAT ARE RUSSIANS, WHAT
DID RUSSIA AND CHINA DO ON THE
INTELLIGENCE END TO HURT US?
>> YEAH, WELL LET ME FIRST SAY,
ALL THREE OF THESE COUNTRIES ARE
SUDDENLY EXPLODING COVID-19 AT
OUR EXPENSE, BUT NONE OF THEIR
ACTIVITIES ARE PUTTING US ON A
PATH TO MAJOR CONFRONTATION, I
WANT TO ENSURE OUR AUDIENCE
ABOUT THAT.
FIRST OF ALL DISINFORMATION IS
ONE OF THEIR MAIN STAYS AND THAT
IS, THEY WANT TO UNDERMINE THE
PEOPLE’S TRUST IN THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE ALSO PUSHING BACK ON
THE SANCTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPOSED AND WANTED THEM REMOVED
BASED ON THE HUMANITARIAN EFFECT
OF COVID-19 AND THE OTHER THING
IS, THEY ARE UNDERSCORING THE
FACT THAT THE UNITED STATES
HAS THE LARGEST OUTBREAK OF
COVID-19 AND THAT’S DUE LARGELY
TO THE IN COMPETENCE OF THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT,
AND THAT IS WHAT IS SURROUNDING
THE DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN AND
THEY ARE ALSO POSTURING IN TERMS
OF TRYING TO CREATE GOODWILL IN
TERMS OF THEIR RHETORIC BUT ALSO
DELIVERING SUPPLIES AND
EQUIPMENT AND PEOPLE AND
PARTICULARLY RUSSIA AND CHINA,
IRAN IS NOT INVOLVED TO OTHER
COUNTRIES AND THEN THE LAST
THING THEY’RE DOING RUSSIA HAS
TIED UP THE PRESIDENT IN UKRAINE
A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE OF COVID-19
AND THE FOCUS HE HAS TO HAVE ON
HIS COUNTRY.
HE GOT HIM TO AGREE TO NEGOTIATE
WITH RUSSIAN PROXIES FOR THE
FIRST TIME BUT
INTERESTING ENOUGH, THE PEOPLE B
AUKED ON IT AND IRAN
IS POSTURING HERE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF WHAT THEY BELIEVE
THE UNITED STATES HAS TURNED
INTO AND I THINK THAT IS WHY THE
UNITED STATES PICKED UP ON A
PLAN FOR THEM TO CONDUCT A LARGE
SCALE ATTACK INSIDE IRAQ, EXCUSE
ME AND IT MAY HAVE BE THWARTED
BY THE PRESIDENT ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT WAS IN THE PLANNING STAGE
AND ALSO, CHINA, BECAUSE TAIWAN
HAS BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL DEALING
WITH COVID-19, AND THEY’VE BEEN
CRITICAL OF MAINLAND CHINA,
THEY’VE UPPED ALL OF THEIR
MILITARY ACTIVITIES AROUND
TAIWAN BUT THEN AGAIN, I WANT TO
SAY THAT NONE OF THESE
ACTIVITIES PUT US ON ANY PATH TO
MAJOR CONFLICT, OR  WAR, WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF POSSIBLY SOME
LIMITED CONFLICT WITH IRAN WHICH
WOULD NOT LEAD TO WAR.
BRIAN:  SO THAT’S WHO THEY ARE
TRYING TO SAY BUT LET’S NOW LOOK
AT REALITY.
CHINA MAY BE EXPERIENCING A
SECOND WAVE NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO THE RUSSIANS ACT LIKE
THEY DON’T REALLY HAVE A
CORONAVIRUS PROBLEM.
THEY GOT A HUGE PROBLEM, AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS ALREADY PAID
THE PRICE, IN WHAT RESPECT?
>> WELL, YEAH, COVID-19 IS
HITTING RUSSIA, LIKE IT IS ANY
OTHER COUNTRY, AND OF COURSE,
THEY’RE DEALING WITH IT IS
ABSOLUTELY UNEVEN, THEY HAVE ALL
OF THE RESOURCES OF THEIR
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE SECTOR
THE WAY THE UNITED STATES HAS IN
COPING WITH IT, GROWING UNREST
IN THE COUNTRY.
IN APRIL, PRESIDENT PUTIN WAS
SUPPOSED TO HAVE A REFERENDUM OF
CONSOLIDATION WHICH WOULD GIVE
HIM THE PRESIDENCY INDEFINITELY.
HE IS NOW CALLED THAT OFF
BECAUSE THE POPULARITY FOR
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS TANKING,
AND THAT OBVIOUSLY IS A GOOD
THING, AS FAR AS THE UNITED
STATES IS CONCERNED, BECAUSE
PUTIN GETS UP EVERY MORNING
TRYING TO PUT A FINGER IN THE
EYE OF THE UNITED STATES.
BRIAN:  THE OTHER THING IS IRAN
IS SAYING HEY, WORLD, WE HAVE
THE U.S. RELEASE THE SANCTIONS.
WE’RE GETTING KILLED HERE BY THE
CORONAVIRUS.
SHOULD WE?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
LOOK, WE OFFERED THEM
HUMANITARIAN AID, BRIAN AND THEY
TURNED IT DOWN.
WE’VE GOT TO KEEP OUR FOOT ON
THE PEDAL HERE, WITH SANCTIONS,
AND THERE’S ONE SANCTION THAT WE
SHOULD IMPOSE AND WE HAVE GIVEN
RELIEF TO RUSSIAN POWER
COMPANIES, ROSS ADAMS, NAMELY,
AND THE REASON IS DEALING WITH
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS AND THE
REASON IS THE UNITED STATES
IS DEPENDENT ON FOREIGN YOU’RE U
RANIUM, AND WE SHOULD
IMPOSE SANCTIONS ON ROSS ADAMS
AND OTHERS LIKE THAT AND
ABSOLUTELY CLOSE THE DOOR ON THE
IRANIANS.
THEY HAVE NEVER BEEN ON THEIR
HEELS AS MUCH AS THEY ARE NOW
AND WE’VE GOT TO KEEP THE
PRESSURE ON THEM.
BRIAN:  AT LEAST IN MY LIFETIME
AND FINALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
REOPENING OUR ECONOMY THERE’S
PRINCIPLES IN THE MILITARY THAT
YOU WANT TO BRING FORWARD THAT
COULD HELP US IN THE CIVILIAN
WORLD, SHOW FLEXIBILITY, SHOW
PERSEVERENCE, AND DECENTRALIZE
THE EXECUTION.
SO FOR EXAMPLE, WHAT HAPPENS IN
PHILADELPHIA WOULDN’T EXACTLY BE
NEEDED IN CHARLOTTE, NORTH
CAROLINA; CORRECT?
YEAH, THAT’S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
DIFFERENT PLACES, DIFFERENT TIME
, CHANGING SITUATION.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO
ADAPT TO A CHANGING SITUATION,
ASSESS THE RISK, AND THEN
EXECUTE VIGOROUSLY, PERSEVERENCE
IS ABOUT OVERCOMING THE
IMPEDIMENTS, THE OBSTACLES,
SETBACKS AND FAILURES, BUT YOU
PERSEVERED NONETHELESS, AND YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE SPINE TO
OVERCOME YOUR FEAR, BECAUSE
YOU’RE NEVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS BASED ON PERFECT
INFORMATION.
THERE IS ALWAYS RISK INVOLVED
AND WE’LL SEE THAT AS WE BEGIN
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT PUTTING
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK.
THERE’S SO MANY RISK INVOLVED IN
THAT THERE LIKELY WOULD STILL BE
SPREAD INVOLVED UNTIL WE
ABSOLUTELY GET A VACCINE TO SHUT
IT DOWN BUT NONETHELESS WE’VE
GOT TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
BRIAN:  AND BE STRONG EMOTIONAL
LY TO GET THROUGH THIS
, BECAUSE IT’S ALL
UNPRECEDENTED.
GENERAL JACK KEANE THANKS FOR